promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur les bonnes résolutions financières
pour 2024 les femmes sont 82 % à en
avoir prise contre 74 % pour les hommes
c'est ce que nous dit une étude du
groupe de gestion yomonie qui s'est
également penché sur l'épargne et là
aussi les femmes sont majoritaires 69 %
ont programmé des versements récurrents
sur leur livrée d'épargne contre 53 %
des hommes alors ça s'explique parce que
les femmes gagnent moins que leurs
acolytes masculins en moyenne 24 % de
moins nous dit lincé et puis les femmes
gèrent davantage la gestion des
ressources du quotidien et du foyer
comme par exemple les courses
alimentaires ou encore la rentrée
scolaire du coup elles optent pour des
placement plus Sécur d'ailleurs elles
sont 18 % à épargner pour aider leur
famille contre 14 % pour les hommes qui
vont privilégier un placement pour soi
comme par exemple investir dans la
pierre ou acheter une nouvelle voiture
voilà premix cité c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite sur
public
scena promixité vous a été présenté par
ngj acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle